mein name ist luca meine lieblings
zuschauer ihr kennt das ja
wahrscheinlich wenn man irgendwie im
radio auf spotify apple music keine
ahnung wo irgendwo einen song hört und
ihr denkt euch die stimme von dem
musiker hat sich exakt so an wie die
stimme von diesem anderen musiker das
letztlich fällt euch dann allerdings auf
dass es doch zwei verschiedene musiker
sind die einfache recht ähnliche stimme
haben und das soll ja vorkommen also ich
meine es gibt locker auch in deutschland
hunderte leute von neben die stimme
ähnlich klingt wie meine stimme gerade
was ich euch allerdings im heutigen
video zeigen werde es absolut verstören
wir befinden uns nämlich hier auf der
webseite von lambert das habe ich in
einem video von shane dawson gesehen in
einer conspiracy theory uns war es steht
hier schon als spruch we create the most
realistic artificial boys in the world
das heisst lambert ist eine website um
eine stimme zu kreieren
hier ist gar nicht gilt und diese stimme
wird anhand der eigenen stimme er stellt
sony feiern produkt bei gegen die
unicorns create your local evita in jucu
whether you want integrierten editor
sowie users can your application das
sind also die drei haupt leistungen die
von dieser website namens lambert
angeboten werden wenn wir da mal ein
bisschen weiter runter scrollen sehen
wir dann hier schon weiß samples von
wegen videogames hotlines et cetera und
hier sehen wir schon deren produkte
eingeblendet also auf der einen seite
custom voice trading juni kathi fischer
company application dann haben wir hier
noch create your own vocal avatar also
created digital voice it sounds like you
could only one minute off of audio und
vocal mvp also integrated digital voice
auf die user cindy application es gibt
also drei möglichkeiten diese website zu
nutzen auf der einen seite kann man eine
komplette neue stimme erstellen die man
beispielsweise für einen unternehmen
nutzt oder für eine er dann kann man
hier mit die digitalen stimmen in die
eigene app integrieren und hiermit
werden wir uns heute beschäftigen wir
werden nämlich anhand unserer
meiner stimme eine neue stimme kreieren
die sich genau so anhört wie meine
stimme create myvoice nun seht ihr schon
befinden wir uns auf dieser website hier
und zwar steht hier recordia voice to be
able to create your world as we have
zero valad recording cent für die more
to be able to create your digital vault
wir müssen insgesamt 30 von diesen
setzen und diesen englischen setzen die
website gibt es leider nicht auf deutsch
aber wir müssen 30 von diesen englischen
setzen ein sprechen so dass die website
weiß wir unsere stimme funktioniert und
woran sie ist und wie sie dann diese
digitale stimme erstellt der hero happy
when he loved it right things den satz
habe ich jetzt gerade ein gesprochenes
ihr seht schon hier unten ab loading
also der wird gerade hochgeladen wels
ecken slade und nun nach zwölf sekunden
steht hier auch ready das heißt wir
haben nun eine welle die recording
also werde ich erst mal ein bisschen
reden
einige zeit ist vergangen meine lieben
freunde wir haben mittlerweile 16 welt
recording und wir brauchen nur noch 14
stück um eine digitale stimme zu
erstellen also die hälfte an die
mittlerweile schon geschafft und an der
stelle möchte ich noch mal ganz klar
stellen auch wenn wir jetzt uns auf
dieser webseite die ganze zeit befinden
die cetera pp das ist nicht gesponsort
also ich mache hierfür keine werbung ich
finde es ehrlich gesagt sehr verstörend
wie bereits gesagt hat shane dawson dass
hier in einer conspiracy theory schon
mit drin gehabt und hat sie mit diesem
programm seine eigene stimme digital
erstellt und das war schon gruselig und
ich dachte mir hey wie wir das werde ich
das mit meiner stimme machen frage ist
ob das überhaupt richtig rüber kommen
wird weil die website ja komplett auf
englisch ist ich rede die ganze zeit auf
englisch und meine stimme soll nachher
deutsche setzte vorlesen allerdings
spreche ich jetzt erstmal auch die
restlichen sätze 1
meine damen und herren wenn du liebes
zuschauer bei der liebe luxus dass wir
gerade der letzten satz den ich
angesprochen habe und auf der website
steht jetzt you have now in afrika ding
stradiot digital audio recording will
improve your quality also wenn ich noch
mehr ein sprecher wird meine stimme noch
besser aber meine stimme wird so auch
schon glaube ich recht gut halt die
fresse du laufen also ich klicke jetzt
hier unten auf trade may digital vault
boy think you for trading symbol stanley
und e mails zu digital voice trading
was
ist das euer ernst no shit ich dachte
ich spreche dass sie alles einfach ein
das war wirklich nach heiden sprech
arbeit und dann bekomme ich irgendwie
jetzt im badisch zwei minuten und die
website hat das einmal nicht
ich bekomme eine mail wenn die kacke
fertig ist wie lange wird das jetzt
circa dauern
[Musik]
freunde sind 16 stunden vergangen
mittlerweile schon der nächste morgen
meine haare sind komplett aus weil ich
gerade erst duschen war allerdings habe
ich eine mail bekommen und zwar your
voice is ready check it out wir befinden
uns also hier wieder auf der webseite
von leopard hier steht immer noch rekord
ihr wollt to improve the quality of the
ballad recording als werden schon 32
aufnahmen gemacht wenn wir noch mehr
aufnehmen wird meine stimme
dementsprechend noch qualitativ
hochwertiger und näher an der realität
hier können wir dann noch einige sätze
ein sprechender und hier unten steht
dann allerdings und das ist neu
dazugekommen you already have the vocal
abbottabad jugendtraining jupiter
including this and recording clicking we
create the voice wir dementsprechend
hierauf recreativo klicken oder am 3 mai
digital voice und da klicke ich jetzt
mal drauf my life would give your voice
edita also wir können jetzt hier sachen
reinschreiben
wie soll eine stimme im mond liebe
schreiben also keine ahnung warum hier
im motiv sind
ich kann jetzt ja irgendein text
eingeben ich war doch seit langem niveau
gespannt bei einem video hallo mein name
ist luca gebe ich jetzt einfach mal ein
mit einem punkt dahinter wir können
jetzt hier auf generate klicken
nutze ich bitte habt es verbleiben und
herren der final im moment ist gekommen
wir haben nun nach stundenlanger arbeit
meine eigene digitale stimme erstellt
ich klicke jetzt of channels
ja
ach der der muss ja erstmal noch was
laden wenn paar sekunden später
er ist fertig ich bin für cras gespannt
ich denke jetzt raus
der name ist luca mein gott oh mein gott
oh gott natürlich klar als ist computer
das hört man komplett raus allerdings
meine damen und herren ich sage euch
jetzt mal gleich hallo mein name ist
luca mit meiner stimme und dann spiele
ich euch danach direkt diese sounddatei
hier ab mit dieser digitalen stimme
hallo mein name ist luca
man hört schon parallelen das ding ist
das ist ja eigentlich auf englisch das
heißt ich gebe jetzt noch mal hallo mein
name ist luca einem klick hier auf
generate das heißt es ist jetzt ein
englischer satz ich habe die ganzen
sätze bisher auf englisch angesprochen
deswegen glaube ich dass wir einen
englischen satz nehmen denen diese
digitale stimme vorlesen soll dass das
auf jeden fall besser rüberkommen mein
name ist
ich weiß nicht ob ich dumm bin ich weiß
nicht ob meine ohren nicht richtig
funktionieren aber ich könnte da mich
raushören dieses mein name ist luca das
ist das ist krass leute ich gebe jetzt
einfach mal als sein golden pick up
girls from the train station later
eigentlich heißt meine freundin jule
aber auf englisch gibt's den namen juden
nicht so wirklich deswegen nehme mich
jetzt einfach mal wichtig auf generate
und das ist jetzt ein bisschen ein
längerer satz es ist schön hier der ist
doppelt so lang und ich bin echt
gespannt wie diese website denen das
verpacken wir ich klicke jetzt
im sample also hier steht ein try to
cold emily batty dancer und klicke auf
generate also das ist jetzt einen satz
denen diese website mir vorgegeben hat
er anscheinend gut funktioniert wenn man
dort seine digitale stimme kreieren
lässt der satzes fertig
hallo mein name ist luca
so einen server
website für ganz ganz ganz böse dinge
verwenden allerdings wenn die website
das ganze noch menschlicher machen würde
dann könnte man damit ja so krass sachen
fälschen sprachnachrichten
aufzeichnungen dinge die vielleicht ein
politiker gesagt hat also die
möglichkeiten mit dieser website
schabernack anzustellen was ich aber nie
für ein bescheuertes wort apropos wie
würde diese website eigentlich wie würde
diese website eigentlich schabernack
aussprechen man könnte wird dieser
website auf jeden fall unfassbar krass
viele böse dinge anstellen unfassbar
viele sachen einfach fälschen faken et
cetera
mich würde eure meinung zu so einer
website mal interessieren schreibt
kommentare findet ihr die technik krass
beeindruckend oder so wie ich ziemlich
beängstigend zudem könnte man ja auch da
meine stimme jetzt erstellt wurde könnte
ich ja noch so ein bisschen trainieren
die noch so ein bisschen verfeinern dass
sie noch realistischer wirkt dann
eventuell in einem anderen video freunde
oder familie von mir anrufen und die
website reden lassen und dann schauen ob
die leute die ich anrufe das überhaupt
merken das nicht ich gerade mit ihnen
spreche falls ihr so ein video von mir
auf meinem kanal in den nächsten tagen
wochen sehen wollt dann lasst einen
daumen hoch bei diesem video da schreibt
mir gern vielleicht weitere ideen und in
die kommentare und ich würde sagen wir
lassen das auto jetzt von dieser website
sprechen
allerdings spielen
[Musik]